I have a mystery item for you yes what
do you think this is I would imagine
some people would think it's some kind
of game or maze or like a game of Go or
something does look like it than that
would it help if I told you that the
little hexagons some of them are made
out of plastic and some of them are made
out of lead people who know who you are
are going to assume this has something
to do with astronomy it does and in fact
the lids a bit of a giveaway because one
of the things that people everyone knows
about lead is that x-rays don't get
through lead and in fact this is part of
an x-ray telescope it's sort of the
equivalent of the lens in an x-ray
telescope so I so the bit that goes at
the top so it's the bit that the x-rays
first pass through before they get to
the detector yeah an x-ray telescope
tends to be it doesn't have to be a
closed tube but basically you've got
this thing kind of up there somewhere
and then you've got just got a detector
down here that just detects the x-rays
that goes over the hole at the front yes
there it is I mean it's kind of the
equivalent of a lens but if this comes
back to how you actually make pictures
with x-rays this is a thing called a
coated mask and it's used on hard x-ray
and gamma-ray telescopes it's actually
used in medical imaging in other areas
as well but in the astronomical
community we put them on telescopes they
tend to be the kind of telescopes that
work at wavelengths that don't get
through the atmosphere so they tend to
be on satellites so for example the
integral satellite which is a gamma ray
observatory and ESA's mission up there
at the moment has coated masks on the
front of it and so either you put them
in space or the alternative these gamma
rays get at least a little bit waned
down into the atmosphere so if you have
a balloon you can you can actually have
a balloon borne experiment with one of
these telescopes on as well so I
borrowed this from a friend of mine a
guy called Tony bird works at the
University of Southampton so this is
actually University of Southampton
coated mask and he's an old mate so he
lent it to me for a week or so it does
have a symmetry it actually has this
sort of strange rotational symmetry that
actually if you if you rotate the thing
around you get back to the same pattern
you started with and this isn't it
really isn't the random pattern the the
pattern of effectively holes the bits
that the x-rays can get through and the
the blocked out bits is is carefully
chosen this is a thing called a
hexagonal uniformly redundant array or a
horror is its technical name for it but
it's actually designed with a with a
specific objective in
mind and I put down because it weighs a
ton okay we need to back up a little bit
and talk about how you make pictures
basically how telescopes works how
cameras work normal optical wavelengths
and actually of course a lot of the
electromagnetic spectrum the way a
camera works is the way your video
camera works that you've got a lens at
the front which focuses the light down
onto a detector at the back
typically a CCD these days which will
cause the light that's come from ISO but
essentially you're taking all the light
from came from a particular direction
and you're focusing it down to a
particular point on the detector and
that works fine at optical wavelengths
because it relies on the fact that
you've got things like lenses or mirrors
that allow you to bend the path of light
so you can focus light down in this way
x-rays at least of the soft x-ray inner
things you can still actually focus
light you have to start getting a little
clever because if you just put a mirror
in the way of an x-ray it just go
straight through if you put a mirror at
a very oblique angle the light will
still get reflected off it so you can
still focus light even at x-rays you can
do it with the same material if you have
the same material viewed face on x-rays
just go straight through if you think
about the atoms within it as the little
balls then if you think about it when
it's face on there are gaps between the
balls but if you take the same thing and
view it very close to a John now there
are no longer any gaps and so actually
the x-rays which penetrated perfectly
easily when it was face on when it's at
the peak incidence will deflect off the
surface and so you can still focus now
it's quite hard to do because if you
think about it you've got a given area
of your mirror if you then put it an
angle like that you suddenly only have a
very tiny area so to build an x-ray
telescope this way they actually build
these nests of mirrors inside each other
each of which sort of deflects a little
bit of light so you can end up forming
an image that way but even that breaks
down by the time you get to the hard
x-ray end and the gamma-ray end of
things nothing you can do will focus the
light effectively so you need some new
technique for imaging and this is what
this is is this is a thing called it's a
thing called a coated mask and
essentially all it does is it throws a
shadow if this were the telescope
supposing there was only one source out
there one bright quasar massive black
hole emitting loads of x-rays and you
wanted to know where it was in the sky
all you have to do is point this
telescope somewhere in vaguely the right
direction and then the x-rays from that
quasar will come through the mask here
and you know where they've hit the LED
they be stopped where they hit the
plastic they just go straight through
and so you've now got your detector
behind which records the x-rays
it'll just see a picture essentially of
this
masks but where the mask appears on the
detector will tell you what direction
the light was coming from just like if
you were looking you know if you're
looking at shadows normally you can tell
where the Sun is in the sky just from
the pattern of shadows so this is doing
exactly the same thing from the pattern
of shadows that this mask casts on your
detector you can tell where that source
was so couldn't you just make that a big
X or a straight line why is it why is it
this funky groovy pattern that it is so
that's because there is more than one
source out there so if there were only
one source you would probably be very
dull but actually almost any pattern
would work because you could just see
the pattern of shadows what's clever
about this is that actually even if you
have multiple sources it can still
produce it tell you where they all are
and how bright they all are so I'm going
to just give you a demonstration of how
these things work with a nice little
optical model so actually I've made one
of these coated masks here this is
actually the same design as the one on
the integral satellite up there in space
at the moment but rather than making out
of blocks of tungsten or lead I've made
it out of a transparency sheet when a
photocopy here's my high-tech gamma-ray
x-ray telescope made out of an old
cardboard box and there's the coated
mask that goes on the top and obviously
then the detector will be down here at
the bottom and so we can very easily see
what happens and shine it through you
can see basically you get just the
shadows of the of the mask and when the
lights in different places obviously the
pattern moves around so by recording
where the pattern is you essentially
know where the light source was so the
clever part is that this is a trivial
thing to do because actually if there's
only one source out there it's pretty
easy to figure out what the pattern is
the neat part is if there's more than
one source as we defined astronomically
and you want to actually look at more
than one thing at once we can still do
it so I need to borrow your phone for
this so for now if the door is more than
one source out there in space so you can
see what happens is you get overlapping
shadows so as you can see in some places
you have white in some places you have
black in other places you have shades of
gray just depending on exactly how
things line up depending on where the
sources are you end up with these
different overlapping patterns
okay dancing fans and it's just it's a
pretty simple simple job to figure out
what's doing what is though the clever
part about these whether it's these
uniformly were done in their ways
whether it's one like this which is
hexagonal or whether once one like this
which is designed around squares the
clever thing about them is that that
pattern of blacks whites and grays you
can use to interpret whatever is going
on in the sky there's never any
ambiguity so in fact that if you like
there's a unique way you can go from the
things you detect that patterns of
shades of gray that you detect on your
detector plane you can go all the way
back to saying exactly what the sky must
have been so there's no degeneracy
there's no confusion there's no possible
multiple combinations of things that
could produce the same patterns of
shades of gray there's a unique way to
go from what you actually detect here
very simply back to what an image of the
sky looks like does that mean designing
these things is a bit of an art form in
the mathematical sense of the word it is
indeed an art form so there's a rather
clever mathematical algorithm that
allows you to just define one of these
optimal arrays that really has no
ambiguity at all between what you detect
and what this guy was doing and the
second question is why aren't they all
the same surely once you've got a
pattern that does that job they must all
just have the exact same pattern on them
so in fact quite a lot of them do have
the same patterns on them but there's
for example different sizes of array you
might want in terms of what resolution
of images you're trying to make what
size of field of view you're trying to
make fact I've really but let me show
you a picture of a very pretty picture
so here's the whole series of these
hexagonal uniformly redundant arrays and
you can see a different order so
basically they're making smaller and
smaller little blocks which allows you
to make finer and finer detailed
pictures and actually the thing that
strikes me about them is they really
rather beautiful
special is the quality of that mirror
that mirror was engineered to be so
perfectly optically smooth that if you
took this two point four meter diameter
mirror scaled it up to the radius of the
earth the largest bumps on that surface
would only be six inches high